These action stars had major roles in really
big pictures during the genre's heyday in
the '80s and '90s, but they all ended their
career with a big question mark.
Wondering whatever happened to these well-muscled
men and women?
We've got the answers you've been looking
for.
Vernon Wells personified a very specific type
of 1980s villain: the guy who always seemed
to have his wardrobe on loan from an adult
club.
It started with his role in Mad Max: Road
Warrior, in which he played shoulder-padded,
Mohawked madman Wez.
Wells also appeared as "Ransik," a recurring
villain in Power Rangers: Time Force in a
role that seemed cut from the same cloth as
Wez.
"If I can't rule the present, then I'll just
rule the past!"
His other prominent role was as the over-the-top
villain Bennett in Commando.
"Oh John, I feel good.
Just like old times.
What's it feel like to be a dying man?
You're a dead man, John!"
These days, Wells looks more like a dad than
a leather daddy, and he has a sense of humor
about his characters becoming gay icons, but
to this day still swears there was no sexual
subtext intended.
These days, Wells has been keeping himself
busy with bit parts and voice acting, but
mostly can be found focusing his career behind
the camera, directing and producing.
He also works with Wolf Connection, a nature
preserve to domesticate wolves and allow bonding
with visitors and campers.
In Aliens, Jenette Goldstein made a name for
herself by playing the tough, no-nonsense
Vasquez.
"Hey Vasquez, have you ever been mistaken
for a man?"
"No.
Have you?"
She also had roles as Meagan Shapiro in Lethal
Weapon 2 and the foster mother of John Connor
in Terminator 2: Judgment Day.
Goldstein remains extremely proud of her genre-and-gender-defying
role, for good reason.
Now she owns a company, Jenette Bras, named
after herself, naturally.
She founded the company when she realized
department store lingerie departments were
rarely accommodating for women with smaller
band-sizes combined with larger cup sizes.
Probably best known for playing the immortal
swordsman Connor MacLeod in cult 1986 hit
Highlander, Christopher Lambert seemed destined
for action movie stardom.
"There can be only one."
But while he popped up in a handful of other
action properties in the '90s, he couldn't
escape the shadow of the Highlander.
When the big offers stopped coming and B-movies
loomed, he decided to branch out with some
new business ventures, including a winery
in Provence.
Apparently, they all took off.
Still, he occasionally appears in modern action
movies, like when he appeared as the villain
in Kickboxer: Retaliation.
Sonny Landham made the big time as Billy Sole,
the tracker from the mercenary team slaughtered
in Predator.
He also made appearances in The Warriors,
48 Hours, and many more '80s action flicks.
His acting career dwindled in the mid-'90s
as he devoted more time to his political career,
but it came to a screeching halt in 2008 after
a radio show gone wrong while he was campaigning
for a Kentucky Senate position on the Libertarian
ticket.
After an increasingly unhinged rant, the Libertarian
Party withdrew their support for Landham's
candidacy.
After that, he appeared in a couple roles
for low-budget horror films like Disintegration
and Mental Scars.
Landham passed away in August, 2017 of congestive
heart failure.
Name a high-stakes profession and the chances
are Jesse Ventura has dabbled in it at some
point.
A Vietnam War vet, this former Navy SEAL and
Rolling Stones bodyguard made a name for himself
as a professional wrestler in the early '80s
before making the move to the big screen.
He got to rub shoulders with genre kingpin
Arnold Schwarzenegger on multiple occasions,
perhaps most notably in 1987's Predator.
Ventura played the bullish, tobacco-chewing
Gunner Blain Cooper in the classic film, and
he almost upstaged the leading man despite
a limited amount of screen time.
"You're hit!
You're bleeding, man."
"I ain't got time to bleed."
"Oh.
Okay."
Ventura made another notable appearance in
1993's Demolition Man, but by the end of that
decade he had switched his focus to politics,
becoming the governor of Minnesota from 1999
to 2003.
Although he started on the New York theater
circuit, Peter Weller eventually headed out
west in search of movie work, arriving in
Hollywood during the action movie boom.
Weller gave viewers a glimpse of what he was
capable of in campy 1984 action satire The
Adventures of Buckaroo Banzai, and Paul Verhoeven
apparently liked what he saw enough to cast
Weller in what would become a career-defining
role: Officer Alex Murphy, a.k.a. RoboCop.
"What are your prime directives?"
"Serve the public trust.
Protect the innocent.
Uphold the law."
The film was a success, critically and financially,
and would eventually be regarded as a sci-fi
movie classic.
Unfortunately for Weller, 1990's RoboCop 2
was a bog-standard action movie, with all
the gore but none of the heart that made the
1987 original a success.
He eventually moved behind the camera for
work, directing several episodes of Sons of
Anarchy and even appearing in front of the
camera for the sixth and seventh seasons.
Weller became a literature and fine arts teacher
at New York's Syracuse University for a time,
putting his master's degree in Renaissance
Art History to good use.
He continues to act though, making appearances
in television shows like The Last Ship and
Forever.
Charles Bronson was a no-nonsense tough guy
even before he started his acting career way
back in the 1950s.
Born to Lithuanian immigrants, he fought in
World War II in order to escape the grueling
conditions at the mine his family worked for,
during which he received a Purple Heart.
After taking theater classes while supporting
himself with odd jobs, Bronson eventually
moved to Hollywood, where he took on television
roles.
In the '70s, Bronson starred in his most famous
role, vigilante Paul Kersey in the Death Wish
films.
"Do you believe in Jesus?"
"Yes I do."
"Well, you're gonna meet him."
That role served him well through three sequels
in the '80s, earning him a rough-and-tumble
reputation he embellished with tales of his
arrests and violent hobbies, all of which
he completely made up.
Bronson's gritty archetype grew archaic in
the '90s, but what ultimately ended his career
was hip surgery in 1998.
He struggled with health problems afterwards,
eventually passing away in 2003 at the age
of 81.
Taking over from Roger Moore as James Bond
was never going to be easy, but it was a chance
that Timothy Dalton grabbed with both hands.
The classically trained actor made his debut
in 1968's The Lion in Winter but had failed
to climb the ladder from character actor to
star.
Bond was his chance to do just that.
Even though he only played 007 twice, in 1987's
The Living Daylights and then again in 1989's
Licence to Kill, both of his appearances were
ultimately well-received by the critics.
"Would you get me a medium dry vodka martini?"
"Why don't you ask-"
"Shaken.
Not stirred."
A contract dispute between Eon Productions
and MGM delayed Dalton's proposed third outing
as Bond and gave the actor a legal way out.
He decided to call it quits so he wouldn't
be forever remembered as Bond, but that's
what happened anyway.
Still, he didn't stop acting; he's appeared
in Edgar Wright's Hot Fuzz, had a recurring
guest role in the tv series Chuck, and starred
as Sir Malcolm Murray in Penny Dreadful.
Michael Biehn owes his stint as an '80s action
star to James Cameron, who cast him in three
of his earliest films.
Biehn played Kyle Reese in 1984's The Terminator,
Hicks in 1986's Aliens, and Coffey in 1989's
The Abyss, giving him plenty of fans in sci-fi
and horror circles.
The most iconic of those characters wound
up being Kyle Reese, though at the time Biehn
had no idea just how big The Terminator would
become.
"Come with me if you want to live."
Biehn told Den of Geek that:
"People talk about it being an iconic movie,
with iconic characters and so on [but] it
was never that back then, and you have to
remember, too, that Arnold was not a superstar.
He was basically a bodybuilder and Mr. Universe."
Schwarzenegger went on to cement his action
hero status with 1987's Predator, but for
Biehn, that star-making role never came.
His most noteworthy appearances since have
been in 1996's The Rock and 2007's Planet
Terror.
Taking part in Planet Terror rekindled a love
for B-movies that Biehn forgot he had and
inspired him to start his own production company
specializing in grindhouse-style features.